suivent le secondaire il reste un gros
mois avant les examens après c'est
sérieux dans la disparition d'elliot sur
incarne le rôle de leoni qui finit son
secondaire 5
comment tu voulais interpréter ce
personnage pour pas tomber dans les
cochons est cadrée mais je pense que
j'étais vraiment bien entouré c'est sûr
je veux dire sébastien m'a fait vraiment
confiance
il voulait jamais trop m'en dur je pense
qu' il voulait que je construise ce
personnage là avec mon instinct qui ont
réussi un aussi bon
[Musique]
gd j'étais adolescente qui sait pas si
loin de moi c gepa je suis encore jeune
donc c'est pas cette époque lui est pas
si loin de moi ça fait peut-être 89 ans
enfin que moi je choisis intéressant de
les replonger là dedans je m'en allais
replonge dans mon adolescence au moment
où tu es tellement frustré je pense que
tout le monde
tout le monde est un peu épais personne
te comprendre c'est que c'est comme toi
que les réponses à toutes je trouve ça
intéressant d'aller replonger là dedans
j'étais souvent répondu si ce monde qui
n'est pas fait pour toi
carl tremblay pour ceux et celles qui ne
connaissent pas la maison soulignons que
tu as joué dans deux films d'anne émond
mais c'est vraiment l'âge de 5-6 ans
donc il y aura plus rond 18 ans que tout
est décidé de carrément être comédienne
comment se distingue à la main justement
je sais pas je pense que quand ces
plates et qui t'aime et je pense qu'ils
comptent vraiment quelque chose finit
pas mal par la voix qui moi je voudrais
que je me voyais rien faire d'autre dans
vie c'est beau ce pilot
je voulais je voulais que ce puits même
si j'avais même pas la maturité plus la
conscience à cet âge-là de savoir
pourquoi mais je voulais vraiment faire
ça et ce qui m'étonne vraiment c'est une
autodidacte tout et de fraude
conservatoire c'est pas des commerciaux
l'auteur commencé ben ouais je veux dire
j'ai commencé quand même jeunes puis je
pense que je pense que j'y pense d'avoir
honte fait l'oeuvre quand tu es jeune tu
que 16 heures non stop en bourse elle
est belle est à prendre ça me fige et se
jeter comme un but
il me rend un peu trop est bonne la clé
c'est un stress va conduire et que je
sais pas si mon nom
j'évolue j'écoute et je pense que ça
vraiment bien fonctionner pour toi
vrak tv on t'a vu dangereux et ça aussi
c'est en déclenchant dans quelques sons
j'ai une famille mon et j'ai beaucoup de
cousins cousines plus jeune que moi
c'est sûr que j'aime vraiment ce public
cible le fait que j'avais envie de faire
ce que j'avais je pense que c'est une
chance en or que tu as envie d'être
influent maxime chercher
comment c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté
de jouer là dedans je me suis dit ouais
c'est ça me tente de sam temps de
l'essayer c'est pour les jeunes 72 vaut
ça marche puis comment les jeunes
réagissent auto aussi eu des 8 et 9
pendant quatre saisons aussi des traces
car maintenant un président à ben oui au
début oui c'est sûr que c'est des
actrices qui est jeune mais enfin que ce
intimidant mais en même temps ça m'a
aidé à bien faire mon travail quand je
travaille avec des actrices qui sont qui
sont bonnes y sont généreuses mais ouais
je vais cameron ça a été ça a été plutôt
intense rocambolesque et je tenais pas
fait comme si c'était ta mère crise
notamment les branches où il a tout dit
mon bouquin mais ça me donne y croire
comment ça fonctionne pas car ailleurs
consenti strictement sur le jeu ouais je
suis en musique c'est le après de
bientôt je vais commencer à enregistrer
mon premier album
j'attends un peu que j'attendais de la
sortie du film j'attends d'avoir un
petit peu de temps mais je commence un
autre film le film d'éric tessier que
j'ai commencé après demain puis après ça
je fous que sais je sur mon album parce
que tous les musiciens du cycle ouais
guitare basse voix un piano un peu de
tout mais j'ai des musiciens qui
m'accompagnent
le sapeur pompier l'hawaiien de manon
pas initiés ont parié contrebassiste
bassiste guitariste accession j'ai
grandi j'ai grandi avec des lunes du
brassens à cause de mon père bien
évidemment puis ma mère qui est une
quête une grande fan de musique aussi
donc ça a toujours été quelques chose
dont j'avais envie je pense que j'adore
le contrôle aussi que je peux avoir en
musique le contrôle des départs en 2010
et simon contrôlera mois tandis qu'au
cinéma mais je travaille tout le temps
c'est pour pour moi un espoir
réalisateur t j'ai toujours besoin de
l'approbation de mon réalisateur
donc c'est sûr que le contrôle kg en
musique y est je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment intéressant merci